hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with Bob wait and special
guest CaptainSparklez oh my goodness
hi everybody okay
alright so we're here back with drunk
minecraft and we got a special map here
called sky jump I believe what wait wait
please read this alright shut up wait
captain Calgary to a new epic sky jump
map sky jumps rules clouds off if you
wish play in survival mode play in
peaceful use Jack boys Abaddon
beautifully he left out the ruling last
time that says Green Drinks
no this is new wait wait Cape all right
whatever anyway so today I'm drinking a
new concoction which is a honey Jack and
Mountain Dew I have no idea what this is
gonna be like but I'm actually pretty
sure it's a very weird combination
disgusting like all the food that I
scrounge together out of cardboard boxes
and dirt it's the only drinks that I
hadn't given the house better than
monster which apparently upset a lot of
people no drank all those four lokos and
that's gonna happen to you yeah that
wasn't thing good girl yes I tried four
loko way back in the day but it was just
absolutely oh it was so bad it's dead
now it's right they kill it it's it
still exists it's like not the same
stuff I just remember that song Cheetos
and takis know what does it never mind
you know what never well listen to your
weird what are you drinking
I am drinking I went classy today mmm
drinking a 40 of Miller High Life mr.
captain what are you drinking um I have
my my favorite drink which is a
combination of Irish cream
butterscotch liqueur and some milk image
it's delicious
that sounds like the most delicious
drink I'm drinking ever clearly powder
yeah I just called a couple packages
[Laughter]
alright anyway that's good enough you're
all doing great let's get this
started drinking three now crap we are
we tied you chug this you're chugging it
it's not a chug drink I've never I've
never tried you something this is
terrible for chugging you know what
whatever we're gonna look like a crazy
person
possibly I drink forties I said drink
three now and then go eyes are watering
from the near all the doors are open
Wade please please don't break any
blocks or anything now uh yeah whatever
I'm gonna get myself stuck somewhere so
all right Wow Wow
find a way to open the gate there's got
to be a button or something um oh is
this a this is a puzzle map like parkour
and stuff oh god it's overwhelming yeah
I know you're not an expert in Minecraft
or anything but this is a pretty cool
stuff I've never I've never played this
game before so Ricky oh we have to drop
the block yeah
oh I see there's Park around the house
yeah okay well oh there's that oh wee oh
hey I got it I got
a diamond and a bonus mission do oh yeah
oh wait they also got to push the button
to open the gate yeah a part of this I'm
gonna win hey hey I open the gate I if
you get a head start I don't think I
don't think this is a contest I'm pretty
sure we're supposed to oh god I'm pretty
sure I'm does anyone know the bonus
mission for chance I got this oh oh
I may read the bonus mission hey diamond
you can find diamonds in the map if you
want another challenge you can search
for the ten diamonds okay
[Music]
mentioned a while ago win yeah yeah oh
oh we did someone already open the
checkpoint Oh what oh no I guess I am
well I opened how this game type works
what jump on a checkpoint is a place
that you go where you can get back to it
if you fall Wow
yeah really really what it is oh I
checkpoint in another one we now
everyone's gonna know how horrible we
are at this game we don't know about you
but I'm in I'm right on cams Myrtle's
tail I'm not Tommy can you do something
about that wait wait their chest their
chests on the tree gone okay I'm getting
more diamonds and you're not I think I
should win for using the most
checkpoints I just had that I just had
to reset my progress because I went for
a diamond was it was I not oh I get it
they're water checkpoints you fly off
you go
shut up wait wait get out of the way if
you're gonna use it do it right okay
well today yeah oh you even kill you
that's fine actually
hey I opened I opened another one where
I'm gonna sit here and watch you guys as
I finish off my drink over there which
way is forward oh by the beacon there's
water I'm not laughing at you I'm
laughing with you no Bob this checkpoint
over here Bob look up what Bob look up
yeah oh gosh where was I
no no that was an older checkpoint God
well I guess that one was pretty close
to this one so there really was no need
to go over here well that was the
fastest I've ever consumed Irish cream
butterscotch
yes it was seemingly fast it's just more
of a like you know a sippy drink it's
more of a savor it
counting yeah that we don't know what
those words mean here the only words we
know penis balls and weight is Doug oh
you and crap oh you can craft things
here if you want and you guys Jake doing
cake you eating cake do you want yeah
would you like I am still climbing up
the checkpoint thank you very much okay
oh really high up in the air and it's
kind of oh god no oh take forever to you
bang oh no I just saw you flying by my
slob
okay on my own I'm never gonna get to
never mind
you know around God know half of the
people watching are not even gonna know
what that was
they all will know that what does anyone
actually know how long this goes how
we're done
apparently Oh Gumby said zombie said
that without zombie said that without
falling no using this Oh
jumped off again oh oh oh who's in first
place now Oh who's in the first place I
I'm just gonna go build a tree yeah no
that was the tree houses are you made
tree houses like six different episodes
yeah stupid Lost Island with the stupid
airplane crash that was one I spilled
stupid arm that we tried to build and
that's when I spilled my drink on my
keyboard I once we were playing and I
don't know I was just sticky lating a
lot of things very precariously and very
very energetically I was like you know I
was and somehow somehow Wade got in my
room and not took my mug of drink and
docked it all over him all over my
keyboard so that that's that's your your
Excuse no it's not my excuse there's a
picture if you look on Twitter there is
a picture that someone found took yeah
our weights in the background are you
this is freaking impossible that's
everyone made it to the next checkpoint
from this yeah yeah just I just dropped
another check I know you need to jump us
go in there sorry bud god
interior parkour yeah yeah yeah whatever
oh never a more beautiful you sound has
my ears a third half Duff heard - I
don't know who's winning now dammit
nope not you shut up sorry Bobby Port
Bob and Wade closer here whose god
dammit oh what the crap where am I you
didn't see I am having to turn down my
audio oh there's a chest at can someone
go get the chest outside probably as a
diamond in it I'll get it fine you know
I'm too far ahead right now I can't I
can't do we snap my progress I hope you
know that at the end of this I'm still
gonna win somehow oh I'm gonna burn I
just drop the next checkpoint for
everyone here Oh mark I'm Wario I'm
gonna win am I gonna win I just ride I
swear to god this this video what I said
Nintendo's gonna find this video there's
something on top of this tower thing I
keep like that's impossible
it is impossible sabe poor Wade to the
beginning it was a checkpoint really not
liking a part I've checked pointed to
just a few I'm jumping
one checkpoint to swim to the other like
I'm just gonna be swimming to these
checkpoints in the next two minutes
you can quit coming down so if Y if I
went into the dispenser here and I took
out all the potions that are supposed to
be saved for you guys to use when you
get here would you be upset from
checkpoint on my own free will
Wow good job what is this what is this
crap with the walls oh god I fell into
the checkpoint for the next spot and I'm
already halfway up that counts yes okay
you can do it I'm waiting for the water
it takes a while when it comes down from
so so high what diabolical bastard who
has obviously is a super cool guy and
I'm not gonna insult it all but I am who
has no life and live this is mom's
basement made this map his mom and Wade
yeah he must be some guy who spends all
day every day just playing video games
and like recording some of it and that
are really weird dude um dude oh no why
did I wait there's a place like all the
way down at the bottom
I could totally I could totally do
something diabolical right now that
would be using this checkpoint to get to
a place farther along in the map but I'm
gonna not do that oh my god you passed
me by a lot oh who did who did Lord
minion
do you see why we hate Wade yet yeah no
I'm gonna I'm gonna catch up to him
whoa oh oh all right oh god this is
nerve-racking okay oh you get the
diamond or whatever that was yeah baby
help us it in I thought these were
already drops already saw the water and
that was to get here you shut your mouth
the piston so that the water goes down
[Laughter]
it's a strategy to not go to checkpoints
cuz then people behind you if they fall
I won't be able to get up but then it's
a gamble because you might get stuck
with that do a jerk hey hey Wade can you
do me a favor and hold it hold right
there for a second no no seriously I'm
dead serious
no we we on to pound townn wait wait
where are you
wait where are you we're for the finish
line of checkpoints not really I'm in
the water
Bobby I see you where the hell are you
I'm I think I just cut ahead in the map
wait boy what oh no what is this oh so
sticky in the first place am i cheating
own these roles lose zombie pork me up
no like I'm cheating don't do it
oh look at this oh hey
is who's finding diamonds getting holler
holler get dollars you may have made
minecraft oh you did you're gonna take
you right back up to the top oh god the
vine how did you know how do you know
that how do i how do i help your
favorite players ah it's probably not
you start well to be honest you when you
make it to the finish line before all of
us you need to look in your heart of
hearts and think yourself that you
really did you really accomplished that
[Laughter]
or behind right now I'm like on my own
and I I don't know where anyone else is
by any chance take the the checkpoint to
the wrong elevator level because maybe
you did that and it put you way in front
of everyone I might have done that have
you guys gone through the house where
you come out of top and jump on the
clouds yeah I think you you got off the
elevator at the wrong floor
if we just get to the finish line and
Bob's been there like dude did I win oh
wait because Bob sure maybe I'm trying
to escape from the finish okay you know
I'm gonna music and then in the in the
juke boxes hey Wade you're going up the
wrong elevator breath wrong elevator you
came too
wrong neighborhood mother Humber the
streets Oh ravioli ravioli give me the
good hey Ravi only last night but it was
you
it was Chef Boyardee mine was mine was
Trader Joe's not Chef Boyardee captain
is the man of the house because Trader
Joe's I mean I guess where those traders
versus Chef Boyardee no no no nine year
olds who are like man I can't eat Chef
Boyardee anymore kiss me gasps oh is it
marvelous just like whatever I find I'll
eat it yeah I just mentioned at the
beginning of this episode a cardboard
end of dirt I saw the Instagram yes you
had eggs from like two months ago just
sitting in your kitchen yeah that was
right I had a live stream then Wade was
here and I was like what's that smell
[Music]
something really bad like in this one
location oh no it is so I picked up a
pan and it was a plate of eggs don't
give the wrong idea I do not live in
squalor I am NOT much if everyone wants
to be like a personal cleaning servant
person no no no no no no it wasn't like
that it's just God it was just you know
it's not like that are you a drug addict
convincing us you don't need an
intervention right now it was just this
one and I forgot about it right Wade
please please but I know I've been an
too you know but god damn it
Wade please back on the bus
oh no you're not gonna back me is anyone
else close to me can you like see my
name i oh
no no someone someone's get oh my god
someone's above oh my god tubular but oh
wait oh wait oh wait did you win or are
you know I should be able to get off
here just can't zombie what's happened -
what happened to Bob did Bob win maybe
you're in the winner's circle and you
can't get out because that's oh oh
there's a checkpoint in front of where I
am right now
Oh God
dingus balls and hammer holy you know
it'd be really fun if I died if I could
fly Milan can you play to where we are
right now make it a fair race I was so
far behind where this is right now are
wait wait I'll show you where I was from
here don't make him fly which means is
the right way I can't I can't guy can't
climb I'm busy and I can't do it don't
know I can do it which way is the right
way the way the way that makes me fly is
oh okay take into a new place that was
beautiful but I feel bad now cuz I
didn't technically complete the whole
course because I didn't I would you what
never feel bad on drunk minecraft but
I'm gonna complete it for my personal
satisfaction to complete the course yeah
personal satisfaction it's funny cuz he
means
hey I fell
personal pleasure I feel no satisfaction
hey caps for this is a family show don't
be bringing yours money I won KY no I
won or did you even complete one third
of this I found the end I have a sign
here that says thanks for playing I hope
you enjoyed the parkour of randomness i
won oh I don't think anybody here really
enjoyed this circle underwater yeah
that's what I did
apparently I didn't win though yeah cam
were you not breaking into the winners
area oh oh so much better than me it was
the most MORTAL KOMBAT fall I've ever
heard in my life oh my god enter jumps
oh we're on the same spy I didn't win
apparently no your spirit is amazing
zombie but I'm never gonna complete this
oh if there's a gate I was definitely oh
god okay wait wait wait
oh that was sketchy please
I would enchantment table jumps I wish I
had footage of all of your points of
views my point of view if you want it
yeah I don't I don't want your dirty
point of view Oh another house another
house parkour jumps I worse at the
houses than anything else we all in this
building or something I don't know where
you guys are
I'm chanting tables hey press that
button that I had you make that blows up
the entire world
listen yeah yeah
suck on that Bob to the victor go this I
don't know I think we should delete the
plan rhyme on Rainbow Road I'm on
Rainbow Road I mean one more everyone to
victory wait is it this thing where if
one person's was before this is where
husband zombie portal you losers yeah we
knew you were way ahead but I mean you
said you were stuck I've done this like
a hundred times now so I damn it that's
impossible feat in any moment you might
be because you took the elevator to the
wrong floor yeah did you teleport me
once there that is a dick I don't know
how to give through here Bob watch watch
I have an idea what if I buy
ah how did you do that have to sprint
jump carry over you have to sprint
without oh oh you guys are oh you're
back in the house yes well you hear that
cap near the new way is that that's now
[Laughter]
I got ported okay ahead of me
cuz zombies got me on speed dial oh yeah
zombies type that pork come in so many
time we're dealing I'm jumping jumping
for why I'm all out of zombie can I get
pretty please
teleport don't should sample this
episode and make a bunch of epic screams
and put the P people have started to
take YT i in the sky of rotting flesh
shut up and try to say something i don't
why what that crap how do i oh oh oh
wait I just got that out of all your
stomp it's zombie Molden he's rotting I
get it I got your funny joke I made it
to the spherical tree island I want to
win I want you already won
I didn't oh I got my victory taken away
from me like Neil Armstrong after the
bicycle race Neil Armstrong whatever I'm
pretty
I think your song I think you're
thinking of bill Armstrong I won I won I
actually get it Oh super chumps
it's simple job wait what do okay I just
flooded the the victory area no no
burning myself by jumping yeah oh I died
fine
wait is that official like did mr.
sparkly bed win I mean I got to the
place where it said thanks for playing
like I stood on the pressure plate and
it took me there and it was like oh yeah
this is confirmed this is Paul
his ass and balls and tips are you ass
and balls and tits cuz that I don't oh
yeah because of you who's got the most
diamonds zombie don't I have the most
yes zombie doesn't Bob have the most
diamonds oh really oh it's a Golden
Circle ah well I guess is he this shows
who's the professional somebody I read
what I think did you actually chug in
like four or five minutes there's only a
it lets me on I didn't have a 40-ounce
but what can I say I'm going backwards
fetch myself another one
[Laughter]
sure wow that was a pretty good series
of jumps I just did that's magical oh
hey hey we're all here um uh girl I'm
gonna drown myself in the victory circle
I I guess that's it I don't know what
else to do EVP no don't kill me yeah is
there some way zombie do you have some
way to end this like just make us all
explode into a giant ball of fires there
have to be an ending okay
can't we just we just get along you say
can't we also get along as you beat the
ever-loving crap out of oi Oh Bob you
might want to look behind you I Bob
seriously you know is that gonna go off
[Laughter]
[Music]
are we doing some
[Laughter]
[Music]